[Music]
hello everyone hope you all are doing
well i'm akangsha singh
pursuing btech and biotechnology from
amity university noita and currently i
have completed my research fellowship
internship from pine biotech and my
research topic was
exploring the tumor protection activity
of vitamin c against hydroxychloride
induced dysregulation
in human breast cancer cells
so my research primarily concerns with
the effect of 2hg and a2p in breast
cancer
2hg which is 2-hydroxyl glutamate
initiates cell level epigenome
fluctuation in the chromatin regulatory
landscape which also accompanied by the
loss of lineage fertility it also
enhances cellular heterogeneity with
undifferentiated stem like epigenomic
signatures the findings suggest
metabolic derangement as a molecular
origin of breast cancer heterogeneity it
also enhances cancer plasticity tumor
cell evolution suppresses dna repair
second a2p is corbit 2 phosphate which
is kind of vitamin c
it eradicates heterogeneity and impaired
to hg growth
helps in lineage fidelity
a2p inhibits cancer cell proliferation
and also counteract adaptive evolution
of breast cancer
research statement after reviewing
various literature i came up with the
statement
to edgy as a key determinant of cancer
plasticity and provide rational strategy
to counteract tumor cell evolution
so i hypothesize these two points which
is by comparing the differential gene
expression pattern of sample treated
with tumor promoting agents against the
gene expression pattern of sample
treated with l2hg and vitamin c which is
kind of ascorbic acid
and second a partial or complete
reversal in gene expression patterns
would assert in the tumor
protecting characteristics of vitamin c
so the methodology that i followed for
the analysis of my study is data
extraction quantile normalization pca
which is kind of exploratory analysis
sra and comparative analysis and
comparative analysis pc pipeline was
there and basic pipeline further
bifurcated into gsea and enrichment
analysis through which we get the genes
and the pathway that are involved in the
breast cancer
so the first step of extracting data was
done from the ncbi geo data set
the title of my data set was
transcriptome analysis using rnac in
human memory epithelial cell the data
set has total of 18 sample
these samples further divided into six
groups based on the treatment they are
gone through
first and foremost analysis done on the
study spca that's an exploratory
analysis
first i ran utilities pipeline on dbio
info server which consists of quantile
normalization and pca two files with log
scale normalization expression table and
a pca summary
first i filter out the gene from
expression table and gene leftover 36141
out of
48670 genes
pca plot was generated with no clear
cluster among the groups
no plot the volcano plot basically
performed under the two conditions that
is the adjusted p-value at y-axis versus
log-to-full chain value on x-axis
this results in depicting significant
differentially expressed genes
the blue area in the volcano plot
represent the significant gene whereas
the red area represents significant
differentially expressed genes
genes which are having negative log to
four chain value will be considered as
sound regulated gene whereas positive
log to four chain value to be considered
as upregulated gene
in both the condition here
the commonly expressed gene are a2 ml1
rich pathway
the plot provides information about the
function of gene which are highly
activated due to upregulation of certain
gene as well as the functions which are
suppressed because of down regulation of
some genes
the circles in the
network indicates the count or the
number of gene present in the pathway
enriched pathway it provides information
about various pathways that are either
activated or suppressed due to the
upregulation or down regulation of genes
respectively
the information of enrichment of gene in
the area displayed on the basis of two
parameters that is count that is number
of gene involved and p adjusted value
which is distribution of gene based on p
adjusted value
hence the pathway corresponding to the
highest quantity of upregulated gene are
highly activated while the pathways
corresponding to the highest number of
down regulation of gene are highly
suppressed
now the keg pathway further analyzed
based on the genes and are for the
filter based on the log to 4 chain
value from larger value to the smaller
value
more the value of log to 4 chain more
will be the involvement of tumor
protecting function will be there common
gene that were found in both the
conditions are dehydrogenase or
reductase 9
keratin 24
and phospholipase a2 group ivf or ibe
unique pathways this analysis were done
on jupiter ide of anaconda python server
using merge function to view the unique
pathways
between the samples
genes are filtered based on set size set
size are basically gene involved in the
particular pathway from larger value to
the smaller value
conclusion and future aspects of the
study are gene with name as na are not
mentioned and on further analysis with
their and symbol ids on ncbi or other
gene banks are not found
and need to be discover function of
these unknown and symbol ids
second genes such as dehydrogenase
keratin 24 phospholipase a2 group ivf
are common genes that are found in both
the conditions of l2hg in combination
with l2hg
as well as l2hg in combination with
vitamin c
these gene are indicative of novel genes
at last all other genes are unique to
its pathways and will act differently
with different conditions
these are some references that were used
for the study
thank you so much have a good day